Talk about positive.
Kevin,
how have you been?
Yeah,
I always liked that it's,
this is the phase that I look at that are so easy.
You're not just positive though.
You're like crazy ambitious.
That's the thing that gets me about you and the rock for sure.
It's like the ambitions off the charts.
Like I know you're rich as fuck.
Like when,
when do you think you got enough?
You don't have enough.
There's no,
doesn't know enough.
I don't have enough because it's not over.
It's not over.
So you know when,
when you put a cap on it yet you're putting a punctuation to it and the,
the,
the ambition comes from seeing what's out there that can be obtained.
You know,
when you see what's out there.
Like what can you mean physical things like when you see what's out there,
when you see where people are really gaining wealth in knowledge from,
okay.
The business relationships that you're able to acquire,
the people that you're able to partner with and create certain things,
different revenue streams.
What I found is as a young black guy from North Philadelphia,
the biggest problem with the biggest problem within our community is knowledge.
We don't know debt debt is welcomed because it's celebrated.
That's all we know.
Yeah.
Nah I'm good.
That credit card on them.
Fuck that credit card up and it is what it is.
They got to figure that out.
I ain't got it after that.
Yeah.
Well you know what,
I'm getting student loans.
They gave it to me then after that shit it is what it is.
I'm figuring out and I put the capabilities.
Your name,
you put it in my name,
we could switch it up.
Whatever they do us to just put it in somebody else's name.
It's welcome.
The hustle is welcome.
The knowledge of banks and what you can do or can't do.
It's fucking,
you don't even get it cause you go to check cashing places reasonably go check
cash place cause I don't want to go through that shift and banks,
I'll trust that go.
I did a check has place.
Let me get my,
let me get my now take $30 whatever.
Let me get it.
The knowledges and given.
So it's not to,
you obtain that knowledge and understanding that you go,
Oh shit,
oh this is why you put money up.
Oh this is,
this is how you increase vs decrease.
Oh this is how you earn on your money.
Oh Wow.
I can gain wealth by investing in what the stock world is.
What,
how many people partake in the stock world?
And is there a part that isn't necessarily gambling?
Is there a low risk part?
These,
the snap,
the information isn't there.
Right.
So it's not true.
I got to a certain level and a certain group,
people where I got it and now that I got it,
I want to give it.
So now I'm going to give it,
I'm going to give it to the people that I know need it most.
And for me,
that younger generation of black people that don't understand.
The cool thing is in financial longevity,
not in now,
it's not in the moment for jewelry,
not in the moment.
For the car it's in.
The longevity is in buildings.
So at the end of the day you can say,
look at what I have,
look at what I worked for,
looking at what I have.
That's mind.
Monopoly is real,
but you have to have the financial understanding.
And I,
I teamed up,
I got chased on,
we do some called financial fitness.
Where's just about me educating people on money,
really how to manage money,
how to,
how to be smart with your money,
but it's coming from a person that fucked up money.
I didn't always understand it,
how old and taxes before because I didn't understand that in the beginning I've
had bad credit.
Credit cards wouldn't take me because I'm maxed out.
Whatever.
I've been there,
I've done it.
Thank God I was able to fix it and get on the right path.
And now that I have the knowledge I want to give it because we simply don't
know.
So when you say the end game,
the end game is getting to a point where I've taken all the knowledge that I've
been able to get over these years and really applying it and providing family
wealth when it's all said and done.
The last name Hart is going to mean just more,
a lot more than just Kevin Hart and comedy hartbeat productions.
Hartbeat digital,
you got heartbeat ventures,
your heartbeat real estate.
There's so many things that the last name Hart will be attached to you.
So real estate,
Kevin Hart and sell real estate,
buy real estate.
I don't talk about yourself,
I'm sorry I don't sell it.
I buy it.
But the reason why is because investment investment.
But as you get older,
you learn this,
you learn it.
And,
and you know,
it's such a thing where you talk about um,
black versus white.
You know,
a lot of people do that and rightfully so.
Like there,
there is racism.
Racism exists.
I'm not unaware of that.
But there is a high volume of it that's,
that's nonexistent to people that have good people.
And when you can merge yourself with good people and follow the paths that you
see that these good,
successful people have taken,
you then become a part of a world and group that nobody expected you to be in.
So for me,
I now have the position to do that and take all of these relationships and all
of this knowledge and take it back to the people that need the most.
I like to share,
I don't want it all by myself.
Now,
are you doing this in the financial stuff?
You're doing this in videos or you like release not a videos?
No,
we're starting,
we're going to start,
uh,
we're going to start financial fitness.
Like I said,
we'll chase JP Morgan,
chase,
um,
Jamie diamond,
very good guy,
uh,
to shine de as well.
They're there help leading in charge of just saying,
how can we get to the people that we feel need the financial information the
most?
So I said,
put me out there like,
let's,
let's go directly to the consumer.
So from colleges,
uh,
from high schools,
um,
senior classes,
junior classes,
going out and talking to people before they go into the next stages of their
life,
about the things that you should know before you're going to speak to them well,
and just share personal information.
Are you going to put this stuff online as well though?
Yeah,
yeah,
you'll be able to track and find content from it.
But I'm authentic.
So I said the best way to really do it because it put me in a position to be
heard.
I want to be heard like,
like it's a different story.
What I explained to,
uh,
the,
the people of JP Morgan Chase just when we were talking about this and as an
amazing board of people,
uh,
that,
that are just figuring this out in the best way to go and do it.
And I said,
you can't have,
uh,
the white guy that's never been to the hood or who's not from the hood or has no
idea how the economy works here and what the real troubles are.
You can't throw that man in the situation to talk to people because I'm not
listening to you from the gate because you don't relate.
I don't relate to you.
But throwing somebody in a situation that's lived it,
that's been in it,
that's been fucked up in it,
made it out of it and is now coming back to help.
Right.
It's a different ballgame.
And that's what I want to be.
And you know,
we have other voices outside of myself.
I'm very powerful voices that are going to do it as well.
But the purpose is to align ourselves to really make a change.
So you can either be the conversation about making change and you can be actual
a part of the action to do it.
I want to be a part of the action and and doing it.
You'll also be able to understand my drive.
You'll get why I do so much.
You'll get why my hand is in so much because I have access to it.
And the question should be why not?
Yeah.
The question shouldn't be,
Yo,
why is he doing everything?
It should be,
why aren't you,
why don't you try to do everything?
Why not?